i just did it in an afternoon the
original list of rules i was playing on
quora
um i i wrote about 40 answers for quora
something like that and i really haven't
partaken in that forum for a long time
now
um i was investigating it and
some kid had asked what what you need to
know
in order to lead a good life or what's
most important to know something like
that and i thought well i'll
you know take a crack at answering this
and i made this list of 42 rules and
it got very popular on quora much more
popular
typical pareto distribution like that
one answer got more
views than all of my other answers put
together
and so i thought that was kind of
interesting you know i touched something
for some reason
and out of that when i was asked by an
agent who contacted me sally harding
of of of cook agency
she asked me if i was interested in
writing something more popular and i
knew that those rules
had found an audience
let's dive into the book because
actually so many of the things that
we're talking about now are are sort of
part and parcel to all of the chapters
here so so chapter one
and what i really liked about this also
is the way you organized it
the the the new topics because one of
the questions we would get often in the
in the q
a that you would get is oh was there a
was there a 13th rule that you couldn't
get in the book and and you actually
mentioned this
in the book that you had you had what
about 46 other
was it 46 42 42 you had 40 yeah the same
douglas adams answer to the universe
life the universe and everything
42 rules which was actually a
coincidence
but i thought it was comical in the
aftermath but there's 42 rules so now
i've written about 20 i've written
essays about on 24 of them
how did when you got to 42 how long did
you give it before you said okay 42 is
enough
because i know you you're pretty
methodical i just did it in an
afternoon the original list of rules i
was playing on quora
um i i wrote about 40 answers for quora
something like that and i really haven't
partaken in that forum for a long time
now
um i was investigating it and
some kid had asked what what you need to
know
in order to lead a good life or what's
most important to know something like
that and i thought well i'll
you know take a crack at answering this
and i made this list of 42 rules and
it got very popular on quora much more
popular
typical pareto distribution like that
one answer got more
views than all of my other answers put
together
and so i thought that was kind of
interesting you know i touched something
for some reason
and out of that when i was asked by an
agent who contacted me sally harding
of of of of cook agency
she asked me if i was interested in
writing something more popular and i
knew that those rules
had found an audience so that seemed to
me to be a place to dive in
so anyways i've only written about 24 of
them you know in the two books
they have them both here you can see how
they're how they're
structured one's white and the others
black they make a match set you can read
each of them independently
and one concentrates the first one
an antidote to chaos 12 rules for life
and antidote to chaos does concentrate
on
the consequences of excess uncertainty
and the second book concentrates more on
an excess of
of of order both of those are
fundamental existential dangers as far
as i'm concerned and
in this universe of value in the world
of value there are two major domains and
one domain is the domain of order
and you can technically define it the
domain of order is where you find
yourself
when what you're doing produces the
results you want
and that's that's a really tight
formulation because
um it gives you a particular idea of
what a
of what a place and time is the place
and time you occupy is
at any given moment is the place and
time that's defined by your current
goal and you have a map of value that
guides you through the actions that are
necessary in that domain and if the
result is what you want
which brings motivation and emotion into
the picture then
while you get what you need or want but
you also validate your theory of
existence
because it's good enough to produce the
results that you desire
and it given that you're fallible and
that you don't know everything
you have to use proximal you have to use
proximal truths
and so something is it's a pragmatic
it's it's a form of philosophical
pragmatism
you're if you make a bridge and it
stands up then you know how to make a
bridge
why because the bridge stood up now
maybe you over
built it you could have built it more
elegantly but it's sufficiently true
so that the bridge functions and we're
like that we're like engineers we're
cobbling together solutions all the time
and as long as those solutions work we
assume that we're right
well that's that's the domain of order
the domain of chaos emerges when you lay
out a
plan into action and something other
than what you wanted
emerges and sometimes that can be a
catastrophe
an absolute catastrophe and in in
your your brain our psychophysiological
uh our psychophysiology is actually
adapted to those two domains
when something unexpected happens
all sorts of emotions and motivations
break loose fight and flight among them
anger among them gets disinhibited
because when you don't know what's
happening you have to prepare for
everything
so you get anxious and then you hyper
prepare which is extremely stressful
so the domain of chaos is extremely
stressful
in small doses it's exhilarating and
that's because well where you don't when
you're where you don't know what's
happening you
have the opportunity to learn and to
expand your map
and so there's always an interplay
between the domain of chaos and the
domain of order but they can each
pathologize and
the pathologies of uncertainty are more
associated with anxiety and nihilism and
depression and
whereas the pathologies of order are
more totalitarian
and then i would say as well the
liberals
liberal types the more left-leaning
types are quite sensitive to
pathologies of order they don't like
them they're
that that's the patriarchy the
patriarchy is
the pathology of order and it's
symbolically masculine something i've
been
you know uh taken to task for claiming
but
the patriarchy itself the idea of the
patriarchy itself is a symbol
the patriarch is a symbol that's why it
has such power
and it's a symbol that refers to the
domain of order
now the domain of order is protective as
well as oppressive but when it
degenerates it becomes oppressive
and i would say it degenerates when it's
based on power rather than competence
but it can be based on competence
you know the the marxist critics and and
and
and the politically correct types they
insist that every element of the
patriarchy
is only a consequence of the imposition
of order
forceful imposition of order it's all
power well no
no it's not when it degenerates that's
true
because you can tell that because the
thing is the domain of order will be
upheld by those who inhabit it
if it's functional if you have to use
force that's already an indication that
it's become pathological
because people aren't playing
voluntarily so so would you say
we're in a degenerative
uh cycle right now that the cycle seems
more
degenerative than than say a building
cycle or you think that that's just the
that's just the play that's always going
on and and you have to figure out your
role in it
well i think the play is always going on
there's like and i don't think
like the antidote to chaos isn't order
and the antidote to order isn't chaos
the antidote to both is the balancing
right the active balancing of them
you used to do this a lot you would say
the the balance the struggle between
liberal and conservatives so people see
me doing this all the time i was
credible jordan was talking about
he was talking about this but so you
think that's it well it's really
important it's really important to
understand that
that the that the antidote to chaos in
the final analysis can't just be ordered
because order itself can degenerate
and so i believe that the antidote is
active engagement with the world
honest active engagement with the world
truth and i think it's also truth
motivated by love
which is a motif that runs through this
second book in particular and
love is the desire for all things to
flourish
you know in in in christ says that you
should love your enemies and
that that's an ins that what does that
mean
and and it's really worth thinking about
is you shouldn't wish your enemies harm
in this
like and by by and i what i mean by that
is that it would be better for
everyone if they would conduct
themselves so that they would
flourish you know and that doesn't mean
you shouldn't defend yourself it doesn't
mean that
that soldiers aren't necessary or the
police it doesn't mean any of that it's
not a weak need statement it means that
if you're
if you have your if you have your
if you have yourself pointed in the
right direction
you don't wish an excess of harm on
on the world you want it to flourish
that's love so you aren't yourself
that way and i do believe that that
requires a certain courage
because the world is so flawed and so
painful there's so much suffering in it
it's very difficult to fall in love with
it
you keep getting bounced off you think
this is so terrible that maybe it
shouldn't even
be but that takes you down a very bad
road
so it's love first and then truth serves
that
and i do think that's the motif that
runs through the old and new testaments
that the combination of those two things
love is the
the desire that being flourish
and and and i do believe that truth
serves that
well that's it so no please finish your
thought
well i also think that people find
meaning in that
and you can everyone can answer this for
themselves it's like
you have to watch and you have to see
where it is that you find the meaning
that sustains your life and
i would say it's certainly not been my
experience that people find that in
deceit
or hatred i mean they may be tempted by
that they may have their reasons for it
but everyone is ashamed of that
and wishes it could be otherwise even if
they don't know what to do about that
so
well so this book the first chapter is
do not casually denigrate social
institutions or creative achievement and
i picked that
quite carefully because again the
liberal types are more likely to
criticize social institutions um
you don't want to do that casually
because they structure things and
protect you in a way that you're
likely not even aware of and the
conservative always says look be careful
when you change something because you're
changing a bunch of things and you don't
know what's going to happen
so be careful but social institutions
can become corrupt even just as a
consequence of aging
and so they have to be updated so they
can't stay static
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't
respect them and then creative
achievements on the other side and
conservatives
for example they have a harder time with
open
people creative people you know the best
personality predictor of
of liberalism is high openness which is
a creativity dimension
well it's easy to dismiss
art for example as especially if it
doesn't exactly speak to you but
it's through artistic endeavors through
creative achievement that the process of
update occurs and so
regardless of your political temperament
you you need to see
these these forces you need to see the
value in these forces
and have some respect for them i think
what happens if you get educated
hopefully is that you get educated
beyond the confines of your temperament
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes
every interview i've ever done with him
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist both are right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell